abone ol
Çok teşekkür ederim bu sıcak
alkışlarınız için yıllar önce bir Banka
şube müdürlerine bir konferans
düzenlenmiştir Ben de davet ettiler işte
Türkiye ekonomisi de ne oldu bitiyor
bunları anlatmamı istediler bir otelin
balo salonunda sabah 9 gittim hakikaten
öyle kravatlı falan ciddi adam da
oturmuş salonda bana bakıyorlar 150-200
kişi falan var Ben daha gencim o zaman
Tabi daha heyecanlı işte ne yapacağım
falan diye düşünüyorsun falan var ya
bitkiniz gah yapmam lazım ya adamlar
bana bakıyor ben onlara bakıyorum lan
sonra aklıma yıllar önce okuduğum bir
kitap geldi etkili konuşma nasıl yapılır
güzel konuşma nasıl yapılır gibi şeyler
anlatan bir kitap okumuştum ben Ve bu
işlere başlamadan önce orada şey
söylediğin hatırladım fıkra ile başlayan
fıkra anlatırsanız salondakiler Gülen
onlar güldü için rahatlarlar onlar
rahatladı ki siz de rahatlarsınız oradan
suyumuza geçebilirsiniz ne bir bu aklıma
geldi tamam dedi
bu okulları bir fıkra anlat fıkra
deyince aklımıza ne gelip Karadeniz
fıkrası ben de başladım temel bir gün ve
bir fıkra anlattım fıkra bitti Kimse
gülmedi gerçekten hiç bir kişi bile
gülmedi yani tamam bir Cem Yılmaz
değilim öyle hani Fıkra anlat ama
olabilir mi çok kötü değil yani iyi bir
fıkra ve anlatıcısı sayılırım Pardon
dedim Siz hangi bölgeden geldiniz meyve
Karadeniz Bölgesi Şube Müdürlüğü davet
etmişler bu karadenizlilere Karadeniz
fıkrası anlatmak de Çok akıllıca bir
işti fıkra bitti onları arkadan birisi
elini kaldırdı Buyurun dedim Öyle Ağır
abi herhalde bölgemidir falan gibi
birisi şöyle ayağa kalktı Ama böyle çok
ağır bir şekilde kalplerini elini
kemerini koydu geriye doğru götürdü
Hocam dedi Bir soru sorabilir miyim dedi
Buyurun dedim Size de karadenizlilerin
neden silaha meraklı oldu
ve yanlarında silah taşlıkları bilir
misiniz dedi Hayır bilmiyorum dedim Kötü
Karadeniz fıkrası anlatanların vurmak
için dedi Ve bunun üzerinde salon koptu
onlar gülüyorlar Ben stresinden
kurtulmaya çalışırken bacaklarımı
titrediğini falan ettim sende de kimin
yanında ne var ne yok bilmiyorum
aranızda Karadeniz var mı
bu ve alkışladım göremediği misin Ha
şimdi his kalmayacağım Dolayısıyla fıkra
filan böyle bekliyorsanız günün sonunda
konuşmacılardan bir tanesi anlatırdı Ben
de bunu beklemez bakın orada şunu
öğrendi bir kitap okuyarak bir konuda
Yetkin olmak çok mümkün değil Yani ben
açtım iyi bir kilo baktım bunu okudum
işte bunu bana anlattıkları iyi
konuşmacı olurum falan işi çok da doğru
bir şey değildir benzer şey Aslı
ekonomide de varsa zaman zaman
duyarsınız Türkiye'de önemli
şahsiyetlerin benim alalım ekonomi falan
dediklerini duyarsınız Aslında ekonomi
öyle çok kolay bir şey diyeceğim öyle
bir tane kitap iki tane makale
Okuduğunuz zaman iyi bir iktisatçı
olmazsınız ilk saat olabilmek için biraz
tarih bilmeniz gerekir biraz antropoloji
okumanız lazım iyi derecede sosyoloji
bilmeniz lazım ve bunların üstüne çok
iyi derecede matematik bilmeniz lazım
Bunlar olmadık zaman yani
konuşabilirsiniz
bölüm futbol maçı anlatmak Herkes
birbirine bir şey anlatabilir mi iyi bir
saçı olamazsın İyidir canım matematik
bilmemiz gerektiği bizi kızakla
matematik çok yoğun kullanıyoruz Ben
bugün ekonomi alanında yazılan ciddi bir
Dergiye bakın baktığımız zaman sanki bir
matematik dergisinde yayınlanan bir
makaleye bakıyor musunuz hissine kapılır
bu kadar çok kullandı ama kullanılan
bütün bu modellere iktisatta
kullandığımız matematikte modelleri
hepsinin temsil ettiği bir şey var
yerleşti Bir şey daha iyi nasıl
yapabilirsin daha ucuz nasıl
yapabilirsiniz fiyatı nasıl
arttırabiliriz kaynakları verilmez
kullanabilirsiniz vesaire bunların
herbirinin hayatta karşılığı olduğunu
biliyoruz ilk satır sosyal bilim olduğu
için bu da öğrendiklerinizi lafı olarak
da anlata bilmeniz lazım Ben bunu
öğrencilerime şöyle anlatıyor ki her
önem bunu yapar mısın Ders anlatıyorsun
şu türevin tekrar bir modeller var falan
bittiğinde bunu ne anlama
ve sözel olarak ifade edebilmeleri
gerekir O bunu söylüyor bunu da
öğrencilere şöyle anlatıyorum diyorum ki
ya akşam desten çıktınız Eve gittiniz
denize sizinle diyalog kurmak istiyor
sohbet etmek istiyorum çocuğum bugün
okulda ne yaptı dediği zaman siz ona
sürekli integrali bilmem ne falan
derseniz annenin zaten anlamaz Siz de
zaten bu konuyu öğrenmemiş siniz bizde
hep böyle anlatırım yıllarda böyle
anladık hiç de sorun olmadı yine bir
dönem böyle yüzleri böyle anlatıyorum
Eve gittiğinizde Annenizi anlattınız
zaman anneniz onu anlamaz falan
matematiksel ifadelerin dışında bir şey
anlatmanız lazım dedim bir gün derse
arka sokakta oturan çocuğun güzel kaldı
ocağın dedi benim annem matematik
profesörü
var bunun şunu gördüm genelleme yapmak
her zaman bütün detayları
yakalayabilmesi imkan vermiyor olabilir
İktisat böyle bir alan Aslında iki saat
dediğimiz şey genellemeler üzerine
kurgulanmış bir şey biz ne yapıyoruz
piyasanın aktörleri vardır değil mi yani
şimdi biz de uygulanan rahat çarpık da
olsa bir piyasa Konuşsana dünyada bugün
yaygın olarak kullanılan sisteme
baktığımız zaman genellemeler üzerine
kurulduğunu biliyoruz ne diyor mesela
mevcut sistem Herkes kendisi açısından
en iyisini yaparsa bütünleşik olarak da
en iyi Ulaşırız ve kabet dediğimiz şey
böyle Eser piyasada şirketler var ne
yapar şirketler mal ve hizmet üretirler
bunları satarak para kazanmaya çalışan
şirketlerin başka bir amacım yok öyle
uzağa amaçları varmış gibi
anlattıklarından bakma şirketler para
kazanmak üzere var bunun içinde iki
bizim iktisatta kullandığımız
modellerden ciddi şekilde yararlanır
hangi noktada üretim yapmalıyız ki
O kırmızı maksimum devir Ya da
maliyetlerimizi nasıl düşürebiliriz ya
da fiyatlarımızı en çok ama şansımız var
mı en yüksek fiyatı nasıl satarız gibi
konularda kafa yoruyorlar sistemdeki
bütün şirketler böyle çalışırsak
kaynaklar verimli kullanılır Sonuçta da
Toplam refah artar herkesle paylaş
düşeni alır asla Sadece şirketler değil
bireyler de aynı şeyi yapıyor Eğer bugün
Bu salonda bulunanlar ve büyük
olasılıkla öyle açık bir biçimde ifade
etmemiş olsanız bile bilinçaltınızın mi
olarak aynı şeyleri yapıyoruz mesaj
şöyle bir örnekle dedi üniversite
sınavına
her girdiğinizde ve sen ilk 1000'e
girdiğiniz var senin puan olarak ilk
güne girip de arkeoloji bölümünü yazan
Duydunuz mu
Yok ya ben çok duymadım ama ne yazarlar
bilgisayar genetik menüsü zaman zaman
değişir Bunlar Biraz önce Hoca da
anlatıldığı Uzay ve Havacılık bilimleri
okumuş Ben üniversiteye gideyim seni
Petrol mühendisi çok popülerdi MSP son
krizler olmuştu falan herkes Petrol
mühendisliği En azından akıllı çocuklar
Petrol mühendisliği okumak istiyorum
falan Şimdi biz de zımmi olarak daha çok
para kazanacak ve yetkilere sahip olmaya
çalışıyor sistemimize diyor ki
bireylerde Böyle yaparsa onların
başarılı olması toplam refah
arttıracaktır filan Ben de bugün size
Kolay para kazanmanın yolları öğretmeye
karar vermişler misiniz para nasıl
kullanıyor bir iki saat çık şimdi size
Önümüzdeki Beş dakika içerisinde para
kazanmanın yollarını anlatacak Bak şimdi
iki gruptan bahsedeyim bunlardan bir
tanesi şurada görebildiğiniz gibi böyle
kitaplar var piyasada satılıyor Ben
rastgele bir kaç tane
iyi bakın buraya koydum mesela sol üstte
yazan iş böyle para kazanmak için
doğrudan Siz zengin etmeni ben size
zengin olmanın yollarını öğreteceğim
diye başlıyor ya da onun yanındaki para
kazan para nasıl kazandırdığı anlatıyor
bir tanesi yok 21 yöntemle para nasıl
kazandırılır bu çok buluyorsanız on
yöntemle para kazanmayı anlatan
kitaplarda var 98 günde para kazandı
diyenler var ama çok sıkıştı nız paraya
ihtiyacımız var çarşamba günü Kredi
kartı ödemeniz var 24 saatte para
kazanmanızı da anlatan kitaplar var
hatta hiç kitap okumanıza gerek yok
yaptığımız yerden para kazanmanız
anlatanlar da var saat pişti gördüğünüz
Büyük olasılıkta Saat köşedeki resimdeki
yazım hatası fark etmediniz Çünkü
hepiniz para kazanmaya odaklanmış
durumdasınız yattığınız yerden kolay bir
biçimde para kazanma yolunu göreceksiniz
Ama yattığınız yerden yazılmış olan fark
ederim ben çok fazla olduğunu düşün
Evet şunu diyebilirsiniz okumak biraz
zor iş Ben bunlarla Uğraşmak istemiyorum
O zaman doğrudan bana ya girebilirsiniz
Bu da bir adam kanaya sadece teşekkür
bana ya sadece kurbanlarda girmiyoruz
biliyorsunuz böyle yani örneğini
biliyorsunuz bana gibi bir zaman ne
olduğunu da öğreniyorsunuz
diyebilirsiniz ki ya danaya girmek için
sermaye gaz ver biraz paranızı olması
lazım ki oradan ben banyoya gireyim O da
yoksa bu edebilirsiniz Bu da bir anten
Bu bir televizyon kanalında yayınlanan
bir şey altın çıksın 16 100 rekat namaz
kılınır şimdi dikkat edin Çok zekice
yapılmış bir şey 500 rekat değil 700l
değil 600 neden bilinç hafta çağrıya
bakarız 600 altın filan gibi şeyler çok
zekice kurgulanmıştır bir fakat şimdiye
kadar yapılan bütün ampirik
da gösterir ki burada gösterdik üç çanta
bir sonuç doğurmuyor yani kitap okuyarak
ve orada zengin olmanın yollarından
kitaplar okuyarak ya da danaya girerek
yada Dua ederek zengin olma şansınız yok
ama bunları size anlatanların bu şekilde
zengin olacağız iddia edilenin sizin
zenginlik beklentiniz üzerinden zengin
olduklarını biliyoruz Yoksa tam değil
para kazanmanın sırrını sizinle
paylaşsın ki söylediğim gibi bunlar
çalışmadığını bildiğiniz için Sizlerde
Biraz önce bahsettiğim şeyler yapıyorsun
İyi üniversitede gelecekte çok para
kazanacağınız bir alanda eğitim almaya
çalışıyoruz Mesela ben size iki tane
isim söyleyeceğim klan simitle birisi
Duydunuz mu duymadınız olabilir bilgisi
birisi Duydunuz mu
de bilgisini duyduğunuz biliyor musunuz
Zengin olduğu için
Allah rast Ümit kim
O ne lan simit Urfa'da göbeklitepe'de 20
yıl yapılan kazıların başındaki Alman
arkeolog olup hiçbir yerden konuyla
ilgilenmeyenler in Bununla çok ismi
duymuş olmaları mümkündür Az önce
sunumda Okyanus bilimci hocamızı
dinledik değil mi yani hiçbirimizin
haberi yok ya acayip derecede farklı
şeylerle seni geliyor Bunu niye
anlatıyor Aslında bizim İktisat tığa
parasal aştığımız ve bu piyasa
ekonomisinin değer olarak tanımladığı
şey bu para miktarları üst üste koyarak
ulaştığımız bir yer Oysa her şey parası
anlaşmak mümkün olmayabilir O zaman şunu
sormak lazım toplumsal defa artırabilmek
için sadece piyasanın uygun gördüğümüz
fiyat olarak tanımladı şeyler üzerinden
yürümeniz yoksa başka şeylerin de bir
değeri olabileceğini bunun parayla ifade
edilmesi mümkün olmayabilir ama bir
diğer olabileceğini bunların da dikkat
bu gerektiğini ve düşünmemiz bakın
piyasa değer denen şeyi nasıl yaratıyor
bir örnekle anlatayım Benim bir tane
çocuğum var işte onları zaman zaman
oyuncakları alıyorum Sizlerde
almışsınızdır eşlik Geçenlerde aldığımız
bir oyuncak var var İskambil kartlarıyla
benzer Veli tane kattan oluşan bir oyun
böyle yandı bir daha Tenis topu
büyüklüğüne ses çıkaran bir alet var bu
oyuncak ya da oyun kartları Ben ölçtüm
27 santime 35 santim büyüklüğünde bir
Kutunun içerisinde konulmuş yani şu
büyüklükte bir kutuya el büyüklüğünde
kartlar konulmuş Çünkü o şirkette
oyuncak öğreten şirkette çalışan
pazarlama müdürü ya da bugün kadın
Asiyem olarak adlandırdıkları çift fark
ettim Ofisi şunu biliyor üstü modelleri
kullanarak insan davranışı üzerinde
küçük bir şey koyduğu zaman büyük para
vermezler büyük bir şey yaparsanız çok
para vermeyi insanlar
Ben bunu tespit etmiştir üzerine mutlu
aile fotoğrafı koyalım bir çocukla Zeki
olacak zaten buradan mezun olunca her
şeyi yapabilecek bu kartları Siz
Normalde 10 liraya satabileceğiniz şeyi
Kutunun içerisinde büyük bir kutumuz
hesaplayarak 100 liraya satabiliyoruz
Piyasa ekonomisi bu 100 lira ları
toplayarak Aslında değeri ne kadar büyük
olduğunu söylüyor Oysa Aynı şeyden
bahsediyoruz ölürüm 10 liraya
satılabilecek yürü o zaman bu piyasanın
alttan başlayıp genel led'i toplayarak
vardı değerler doğru şeyi gösterir bakın
bir tane örnek vereyim size milli gelir
müzik Saçlar çok atıfta bulunduğu
şeylerden bir tanesi de ülkelerin milli
gelirlerine göre sıralarız onlara
bakarak Vefa seviyelerini olduğundan
falan bahsedelim Türkiye Müslüman Sayın
açıklanacak Martin ortasında büyük
olasılıkta 2019yılı için kişi başına
düşen milli gelir 9 bin dolar civarında
bir rakamı açıklandı
yok ki bende çağrılarda televizyonlara
gidip geçen sene şu kadar bu sene bu
kadar olmuştuk Finlandiya'da bilmem ne
kadar büyük çocuk falan gibi şeyler
söyleyeceğim hepimiz bunu yapıyoruz ama
doğru bir gösterge değil Neden biliyor
musun Bugün Türkiye'de çalışan
insanların kamu kesimi bir kenarda
bırakırsak yaklaşık yer ya yakını asgari
ücret kazanıyor yaklaşık yarı bu Türk'ün
verilen de attım Yüzde 47 ama biz bunu
50'ye yuvarlayıp konuşabiliriz asgari
ücret kazanıyor birikimin yılında Kureyş
aldığımız zaman asgari ücret kazanan
birisinin yıllık geliri 4 bin dolar
civarında bir rakam yapıyor şu ortalama
9000 dolar asgari ücret kazanan ülke
nüfusunun yarısı O da 4000 dolar bu
ifade bile doğru değil Neden biliyor
musunuz gene işimiz kişi başına gelen
bahsettiğimiz için o asgari ücret
kazanan kişi ailede gelir elde eden tek
kişi ise genellikle öyle büyük
çoğunluğunda ön En azından o gelirde
ailedeki kişi sayısı
bu Deniz lazım gerçek rakam
olabilmesinin ortalama Türkiye'de dört
kişi olsun anne baba iki de çocuk var
sayarsanız o 4000 dolar da dörde
görmeniz lazım ortaya çıkan rakam bin
Şimdi biz ortalamadan yürüyoruz kişi
başına düşen gelir 9000 dolar diyoruz
ama bin dolar yıllık ve bununla yaşamak
zorunda kalıyor dünyada bu işler böyle
yapıyor aslında işte bakıyoruz
topluyoruz dünyanın toplam geliri öyle
söyleyeyim 80 trilyon dolar civarı dünya
kırmızı su kadar bir bu kadar büyüdü
gibi şeyler söylüyoruz bunu da değer
olarak tanımlıyoruz Ama ben diyorum ki
değer kavramını böyle parasal laştırma
da başka şekilde tanımlamakta mümkün
Mesela bir örnek gösterir Biraz önce
bahsettiğim oyuncağı aldığınız zaman
içinden oyuncu açıkladıktan bir süre
sonra okutuyoruz sokacaksınız
sokağımızdaki çok toplanması İki gün
sonra ne Yemezler sokağınız aşağı yukarı
böyle bir şeye benzer bir
13 ay toplanmasını ya benzese buna
benzer O zaman şunu soralım çok
toplamanın değeri nedir ver bunu parasal
laştırmak mı geldi bunu karşıladı yani
Instagram'da dolaşmak çöple dolu bir
sokakta dolaşmaktan daha mı fazla
kıymeti şimdi düşün Instagram'da sonra
falan paylaşıyorsun Sabah evden
çıktığını sokağınız böyle bir soru çekip
koyar mısınız ben bu sokakta yaşıyor o
zaman nedir Bunun değeri ne yapmak lazım
bu işi yapanlara şu anda Türkiye'de
yaklaşık asgari ücreti vardır ücret
ödeniyor bunlara yeterli mi ya
yaptıkları için değeri bu kadar mı demek
lazım topladıktan zaman bu hale
geleceğini biliyoruz diyebilirsiniz ki
işsiz sayısı çok fazla ise sayısı çok
olduğu için onlar olmasa başkası
yapabilir O zaman şunu sormak lazım
insanların çaresizliğinden yararlanmak
lazım yoksa sisteminde Eğer olarak
tanımladı ve parasal aştı bir şehir
farklı bir biçimde ifade etmek
biz bu insanları biliyorsunuz burada 8
tanesinin resmini gösteriyorum ama
dünyada en zengin ilk mm kişinin toplam
serveti en zengin ilk iki Bu salonda
oturanlar iki katı kadar bir insandan
bahsediyorum toplam serveti gibi dünyada
en düşük gelire sahip olan 4.6 milyar
kişinin Buda dünyanın toplam nüfusunun
yaklaşık 162s derdi servetinden fazla
şimdi görünmez el dediğimiz şey her şey
iyi kullanıp Sonuçta herkese hakettiği
şeyi paylaştırılacak bir sonuç doğuruyor
olsaydı bu sonuçla karşı karşıya kalmaz
demek ki bir yerlerde yanlışlar var ve
bu fotoğraf benim memleketim olan
Malatya'dan bir fotoğraf Malatya'da
Malatya Mensucat fabrikası bir fabrika
vardı yılların Cumhuriyetin ilk
yıllarında kurulan şeker fabrikalarını
eksi Fabrikalar falan var bu onlardan
bir tanesi Diren fazla işçinin çalıştığı
dönemde üç bine yakın insan çalışıyor
burada bu fabrikanın yüzme havuzu vardı
bu yüzme havuzu bakın bir resim daha
göstereyim burada spor müsabakaları
yapılıyordu ailelerin çocukları buraları
kullanabiliyorum filan sonra benim gibi
saçlar çıktı dediler ki ya bu çok önemli
bir şey değil seksi üretiyorsunuz
bırakın havuz işini başkaları yapsın
Bunlar tekstili şekilde üretirler sebze
daha çok para kazanırlar daha iyi Havuz
hizmetine başkasına satın alabilirler
değil mi Sonuçta kaynakları kullanımı
böyle birşey Burası kapandı yerinde şu
var bir alışveriş merkezi alatya farklı
olarak Biraz önce resimde gördüğünüz
fabrikada çalışan insanların torunları
bugünkü alışveriş merkezinde Çin'de
üretilen sentetik Tekstil ürünlerini
satmakla hayatlarını kazanmaya
çalışıyorlar Üstelik bırakma Koza
gitmeye orada kazandıkları parayla o
mağazalarda satılan sentetik ürünlerden
bile ne kadar alacakları konusunda çok
ciddi tereddütler var
de diyebilirsiniz ki En azından işleri
var Hayır En azından işleri şu anda
olabilir ama teknolojideki bu gelişmeye
bağlı olarak Yarın iş sahibi olma
olmayacakları konusunda ciddi tereddüt
lerimiz var biliyorsunuz Amazon
Amerika'da işte kasiyerin olmadığı
tezgahların olmadığı mağazalarda
sensörler kameralar vesaire girip
istediğiniz alıp çıkıyorsunuz
hesabınızdan para tahsil ediyor O
teknoloji bugün bu alışveriş merkezinde
Dükkanı bulunanlar tarafından
alınabilecek kadar ucuz hale geldiğinde
bugün tezgahtar olarak çalışanların da
yarın ne iş yapacakları konusunda benim
çok ciddi Endişelerim Bak o zaman şunu
sormak lazım görünmezler kaynakları acil
bir buçukta dağıtıyorsa bizim başka bir
şey yapmamız gerekmez evet sosyal devlet
dediğimiz şey sadece Anayasa'da yazılı
olan bir şey değil hayatta karşılığı
olan bir şey olmak zorundadır Altta
kalanın canı çıkmadığı bir dünyada
yaşamak umuduyla Hoşçakalın
abone ol